Now to close out the course here. Let's just go through a few leaving thoughts here
This is slightly more advanced. So if you've got this far and you think that's that's good enough for me
That's great. And I hope it's been really valuable for you
But especially if you're more of a maybe a technical designer or an engineer
You might want to start thinking about a few different methodologies
Which I just wanted to introduce to you. I wish you could then take on your learning journey with you
so
Casting on a case-by-case basis you saw us casting to the game instance
For example when we had to get variables from there, so very simple to implement you saw us casting. It's easy to digest
It can be difficult to maintain
You know you saw us casting multiple times
So it leads to a duplication of work and casts can be expensive
Because you're cast into the entire class and anything that's referenced in that class. So
Casts, you know, there's a small prototype small games, you know, don't don't be too
Hard on yourself if you're casting a lot
But as games scale casts can be expensive and come with memory overheads
Exactly, like when we were talking about the get all actors of class function from earlier in the slide deck
Also, you can use inheritance which saves a lot of work. So you saw us using classes that inherited from
parent classes
Which you know does save you a lot of time when you can get a lot of stuff for free
You saw us using that third-person mannequin that came for free essentially
It can lead to bloated inheritance. You know, we didn't necessarily use everything in that third-person character
You know so that you know, there's bloated
Elements that can come there
They can be difficult to then break apart if we're inheriting too much and you know again, especially as you scale in
They may become a hindrance also using interfaces, which we did not touch upon
But interfaces are a very lightweight and no inheritance of possibility
Possibly a relevant data because you just send packets of data using an interface. So that gives us some really nice modularity
So if you want to look into using blueprint interfaces in Unreal Engine
That that is a good blueprint communication tool
But it can lead to some code duplication. And and so just make sure you're paying attention when you're using interfaces
And we're also looking at hard reference in here
So looking at these examples here
Whenever you create a direct reference to another actor
You'll see the blue
Reference icon here in the bottom left-hand corner where the red arrow is you can see that blue little capsule
and
When we were talking about casting before and we had to cast to an actor it pulls with it all of its reference data
So if I casted to this some actor class, which is at the top of the blueprint window here
Not only would it cast this actor it would cast and pull in the some texture because it's hard referenced now
If I move to soft references at the bottom left-hand corner here
You can see that that is a more teary kind of color and that is now a soft reference
Which it gives you references to the actor in class. Maybe it's a sound base
You you asset in your content browser, which you can then use to async load in this example
So again, this is more technical design territory
and maybe engineering territory, but just thinking about
Hard and soft referencing in your project will save a lot of overhead if you understand that concept
So if that's something you want to look into I definitely recommend you explore that further and that wraps us up
I really hope the gameplay framework wasn't too intimidating for you
And at least gives you a very good starting point
Especially if you're coming from other engines or all the tool sets and you were just unsure
What data was available the communication between the different?
Framework classes and also just where to store your data
Hopefully, you know the little workshop that we did was a really helpful introduction of just how we might communicate across classes
So really hope you found this course useful and thank you again for watching